a world so grounded in reality it's
sometimes hard to forget that Greene
wrote this before the pandemic and not
during while there are many parallels to
our current climate a beautifully
foolish endeavor is a hopeful read good
morning Hank it's Tuesday and that was
from Delphine Aviv Barbie arrows glowing
USA Today review of your second novel a
beautifully foolish endeavor which comes
out today Hank and I will be live at 7
p.m. Eastern Time here at the
vlogbrothers channel to celebrate but in
the meantime Hank I want to tell you how
much your book means to me and why with
my thoughts being punctuated by the
wonderful reviews the book has gotten it
really is a hopeful novel and I need
hope and not in some abstract or
philosophical way like I need it to get
out of bed in the morning for me despair
isn't just unpleasant it's dangerous and
flimsy or simplistic notions of hope
just don't do much to counteract my
despair and I think your book manages
one of the hardest tricks in fiction and
in life it never minimizes or denies the
horrors and suffering and injustice of
life but it also acknowledges that there
are other truths that there is beauty
and Wonder and kindness that's the kind
of hope I find useful and I really
needed it right now so thank you in a
starred review book with says a raucous
boldly inventive tale of alien
technology social media and influencers
the limits of the human mind and the
lengths humans will go to get what they
want it really is a raucous tale I think
it's harder to make readers laugh out
loud than it is to make them cry
although a beautifully foolish endeavor
did both to me of course in many ways
it's a parable for our time and it's fun
to find connections between my world and
the world in which the characters live
but also because you've drawn the
characters in the novel so carefully I
care about them on their own terms and
in their own world which is something I
love in a novel one of the gifts of
reading fiction for me is that it's a
way out of myself like even the people
in my life who are closest to me I often
see in the context of myself my spouse
my children my brother etc but in a
beautifully foolish endeavor Robin and
Maya and Andy aren't my anything and
seeing the world through their eyes
really is a kind of magic also in a
starred review library journal wrote
throughout this adventurous witty and
compelling novel Greene delivers sharp
social commentary on the power of social
media and both the benefits and
horrendous consequences that follow when
we
too much of ourselves to technology so
your first book an absolutely remarkable
thing was the main reason I quit using
the social internet back in 2018 reading
that book I became aware of how
profoundly online experience had begun
to fracture my attention how it had
encouraged me to seek things I didn't
actually want and how much my daily
experience of being alive was being
shaped by private corporations
monetizing my attention a beautifully
foolish endeavor is an even bigger and
more ambitious novel and as a result it
has me thinking about not just how I use
my phone but also how I use my
consciousness to what ends and to whose
benefit book riot says in plot as well
as form a beautifully foolish endeavor
warns against the consolidation of human
power and makes a persuasive case for
collaboration in both storytelling and
problem-solving if you're looking for a
novel that will offer escapism alongside
stinging social commentary and just the
right amount of cautious optimism for
humanity's future this might be the
perfect read I couldn't agree more Hank
a beautifully foolish endeavor is
available now wherever books are sold
and we'll be launching the book tonight
at youtube.com slash vlogbrothers at 7
p.m. I hope to see lots of y'all there
more information as well as some places
to discuss the book with other
nerdfighters can be found in the
doobly-doo below hank again
congratulations I am so happy for you
and also in awe of you and I'm just such
a big fan of yours I'll see you tonight